.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Eine unangenehme Situation
hatten wir gerade letzten Monat.
Wir wurden
von einer Familie in Bern gerufen.
Die wollten wir begleiten.
Dann kamen wir vor Ort an
und sie schauten etwas skeptisch.
Sie wollten uns kaum begrüssen.
Sie fragten,
ob wir die aus Grafenried seien.
Ich sagte, dass wir u.a.
auch in Grafenried seien.
"Dann können Sie
gleich wieder gehen."
"Sie haben schlechte Referenzen."
2015.
Als ich Kevin Huguenin zum
ersten Mal mit der Kamera begleitete,
war er nicht der Abgelehnte,
sondern der Shootingstar
der Schweizer Bestatterszene.
Mit 15 gründete er
sein eigenes Bestattungsunternehmen.
Den Leichenwagen durfte Kevin
noch nicht selber fahren.
Sein 30er-Mobil hingegen schon.
Wie war das konkret, als du
die erste Leiche präpariert hast?
Konkret? Ja, ein spezielles Gefühl.
Ich hatte noch nicht oft
bzw. noch nie mit dem Tod zu tun.
Ein toter Mensch
ist anfangs komisch.
So kalt und ruhig.
Das sieht zwar friedlich aus ...
Das war ein spezielles Gefühl.
Innerhalb von fünf Jahren
baute er sich ein Geschäft auf -
mit acht Mitarbeitenden,
sieben Filialen
und bis zu 40 Aufträgen pro Monat.
Mit seiner jugendlichen Frische
dachte er die Branche neu
und sorgte schweizweit für Furore.
Ich kam mit zehn Jahren
auf die Idee.
Da war mein Götti gestorben.
Da kam ich zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben in Kontakt mit dem Tod.
Und mit den Abläufen
einer Beerdigung.
Das begann mich zu faszinieren.
Beim Bestattertreffen
stiess er bei seinen Berufskollegen
und -kolleginnen indes auf Skepsis.
Was hast du gelernt?
- Nichts. Ich bin direkt hier rein.
Wie?
- Ich bin direkt in dieses Business.
Aha.
Willst du nicht noch etwas machen?
Nein. Ich will das hier machen.
Dem Höhenflug
folgte 2020 der Absturz:
Er landete
vor der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Die Berner Staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen den jungen Bestatter
wegen Wucher,
Betrug und Urkundenfälschung.
Ausserdem wurde ihm
pietätloses Verhalten gegenüber Ver-
storbenen und Trauernden vorgeworfen.
Die Medien
berichteten auch darüber ausführlich.
Elf Monate prüfte die Staats-
anwaltschaft alle Vorwürfe minutiös.
Sie kam zum Schluss,
er habe sich nicht strafbar gemacht
und hielt fest,
der Umgang in der Branche sei geprägt
von Skepsis und Missgunst.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft stellte das
Verfahren gegen Kevin Huguenin ein.
Obwohl seine Unschuld
offiziell bewiesen ist,
steht der mittlerweile 23-Jährige
vor einem riesigen Scherbenhaufen:
kaum noch Aufträge, nur noch
ein Mitarbeiter auf Freelance-Basis
und sein Ruf ist ruiniert.
Ich begleite ihn
die kommenden zwölf Monate.
Ich will wissen, was er jetzt macht.
Wie damals in der Startphase 2015
stapelt Kevin Huguenin seine Särge
wieder in einer kleinen Garage.
Er hat sich
nichts zuschulden kommen lassen.
Trotzdem hat er im letzten Monat
nur drei Aufträge erhalten.
Google vergisst nie, das ist klar.
Das finde ich verrückt
in unserer heutigen Gesellschaft:
Man kann jemanden vorverurteilen,
ohne dass das rechtliche
Konsequenzen nach sich zieht.
Nur am Ende eines Berichts
hinzuschreiben,
es gelte die Unschuldsvermutung ...
Das finde ich traurig.
Das ist sehr schlimm.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
was man dagegen machen kann.
Für ihn ist klar:
Hinter vielem steckt die Konkurrenz.
Von Anfang an sei er Berufskollegen
ein Dorn im Auge gewesen -
mit Bestattungen unter 2'000 Fr.
und der Abholung von Verstorbenen
im ganzen Kanton.
Das sei branchenunüblich.
Nach Einstellung der Untersuchung
meldeten sich
einige Berufskollegen bei Kevin
via E-Mail und Presse mit den Worten:
"Wir reichen die Hand, wenn du dich
an minimale Regeln hältst."
Einer, der auf diesem Bild ist,
hat mir gedroht,
als ich in der Region Bern anfing:
"Kevin,
ab jetzt musst du aufpassen."
"Wir schicken jemanden,
der dir Manieren beibringt."
Als ich mein Büro in Münchenbuchsee
eröffnete ...
Das war mein erster Standort.
Da kriegten wir sofort eine Anzeige
des ortsansässigen Bestatters.
Es sei unlauter, was wir machen.
Wir seien nicht mal angeschrieben.
Man hat immer versucht,
mich sofort wegzuräumen.
Das ist halt einfach traurig.
Adrian, tschau. Wie geht es?
- Ja, gut. Und bei dir?
Gut so weit.
Adrian Willimann, Sargschreiner
aus dem Luzerner Hinterland.
Das wäre der Extra B.
Willst du den Wagen oder ...- Ja.
Er kennt die Schweizer Bestatterszene
wie kaum ein Zweiter.
Willimann
ist seit 40 Jahren in der Branche
und hat Kevins Geschichte
von Anfang an miterlebt.
Das ist hier.
Weisse Bespannung, genau.
- Okay.
Das wäre auch noch ...
- Den bringe ich das nächste Mal.
Das ist schon gut.
Merci vielmals, Adrian.- Gut.
Es ist einfach ...
Der Markt der Bestatter
ist etwas wild.
Das Ganze ist eigentlich
auch nicht geregelt.
Und jede Region ist anders.
Und immer, wenn ein Neuer kommt,
versuchen zwei oder drei,
den kaputtzumachen.
Es ist auch komisch ...
Viele Leute kennen Kevin nicht mal.
Auch viele Leute aus dem Verband
kennen Kevin nicht persönlich.
Aber man schiesst einfach.
Aber so ist das Leben.
Kevin hat einen Schuss vor den Bug
erhalten.
Aber er wird das machen.
Ich muss eines sagen:
Er ist immer offen.
Er hat immer ein Lachen im Gesicht.
Er ist mir gegenüber sehr korrekt.
Wenn ich nur solche Kunden hätte,
wäre das super.
Also, Kevin, bis zum nächsten Mal.
- Adrian, merci vielmals.
Bis bald. Merci.
- Viel Erfolg.
Ich treffe Kevin
mit seiner Freundin Lia.
Sie hat ihn in dieser
schwierigen Zeit unterstützt.
Sie ist die Tochter einer
ehemaligen Mitarbeiterin von Kevin.
Seit drei Jahren
sind die beiden ein Paar.
Für mich
war es sehr, sehr schlimm.
Also ... Ich litt stark mit.
Es wurde natürlich
irgendwie auch zu meinem Problem.
Das ist teilweise
auch meine Existenz.
Seine Probleme
sind auch meine Probleme.
Das war eine sehr schwierige Zeit.
Was habt ihr gemacht?
Viel darüber gesprochen.
Ja, und einfach abgewartet.
Ja.
- Wir waren füreinander da.
Wirklich.
Ich sagte ihm jeweils, er dürfe das
alles nicht persönlich nehmen.
Dass man da wie eine Mauer
für sich aufbauen muss.
Damit man selber nicht kaputtgeht.
Ja, aber ...
Ja, es ist ein kleiner Teil
dieser Gesellschaft.
Es gibt so viele gute Leute.
Das hat mich ein Stück weit
auch etwas aufgebaut.
Kevin wurde oft
sehr persönlich angegriffen -
auch von einem alteingesessenen
Berner Bestatterehepaar:
Jürg und Iris Beutler.
Sie schrieb in der "Berner Zeitung"
einen Leserbrief über Kevin.
Er gab ihm beim Bestatteressen
den Rat,
er solle doch zuerst
eine Lehre machen.
Für die beiden liegt das Hauptproblem
im Zwischenmenschlichen.
So wie ich Kevin kennenlernte,
war halt eher ...
... eine Arroganz da,
dass er einfach dachte ...
Er hatte natürlich den Babybonus.
So mit 15, 16.
Er dachte, das funktioniere schon.
"Da muss man
nur im Internet recherchieren
und dann ist man Bestatter."
Ich war auch sechs Jahre angestellt
und machte mich dann selbstständig.
Ich bin das jetzt seit 43 Jahren.
Ich hätte mir nie erlaubt ...
... so aufzutreten.
Ich habe mir immer überlegt,
wie ich als 16-Jährige war.
Oder als 18- oder 20-Jährige.
Ich wäre völlig unfähig gewesen.
Also, nur schon, um etwas zu sagen.
Und umso mehr,
um ein Geschäft zu führen.
Es gibt für alles
eine Zeit im Leben.
Die Zeit der Jugend ist ...
... extrem wichtig
für einen jungen Menschen.
Mit 16
kann man sehr viel kaputtmachen.
Auf die ganze Jugend
zu verzichten ...
Also, nicht Party zu machen,
kaum je Ferien usw.,
bis das Geschäft
ein bisschen läuft ...
Das beschäftigt mich als Frau
und Mutter und Lehrerin viel mehr.
Aber er hat das freiwillig gewählt.
- Genau.
Da frage ich mich ...
Da frage ich mich halt auch,
wo die erziehungsberechtigten Leute
sind.
In welchem Austausch
sind Sie mit ihm,
wenn Sie ihm z.B.
im Krematorium begegnen?
Ich grüsse ihn ganz normal.
Ich habe ihn
schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Gestern sahen wir ihn
zum ersten Mal wieder.
Ich grüsste einfach normal.
Ja.
Und Sie?
Ich sehe ihn nicht.
Für mich ist das
eine sehr grosse Enttäuschung.
Ich drehe mich ab.
Kevins Leichenwagen
ist nicht mehr angeschrieben.
Zu oft
sei er unterwegs angefeindet worden.
Ein halbes Jahr ist vergangen seit
der Einstellung der Untersuchungen.
Einen Drittel der monatsüblichen
Aufträge hat er wieder.
Jetzt können wir etwas durchatmen,
ein bisschen aufatmen.
Wir haben heute
wieder einen Trauerfall erhalten,
den wir begleiten dürfen.
Da durften wir schon die Frau
des jetzt Verstorbenen bestatten.
Es ist sehr schön,
wenn man wieder eine Chance bekommt
und man sich auch beweisen darf.
Lia packt seit zwei Jahren
ebenfalls in Kevins Unternehmen an.
Es ist sicher nicht einfach,
wenn man plötzlich
einen Bestatter als Freund
und mit Verstorbenen zu tun hat.
Also: Hut ab für Lia.
Nicht alle können damit umgehen.
Wenn man das dann spürt und auch die
Emotionen der Leute mitkriegt ...
... ist das etwas anderes.
Man muss lernen, damit umzugehen.
- Wie gehst du damit um, Lia?
Eigentlich sehr natürlich,
allgemein.
Man kam halt so rein.
Ich bin da reingerutscht.
Aber ich denke, der Beruf
hat mich in dem Moment ausgewählt
und nicht ich den Beruf.
Zuletzt noch die Lieblingsgegenstände
des Verstorbenen.
Die Fernbedienung darf nicht fehlen.
So hat der Mann sich das gewünscht.
Sie fahren mit dem Verstorbenen
ins Krematorium Bern.
Es war das einzige Krematorium,
das Kevin von Anfang an erlaubte,
Verstorbene zu bringen.
Den anderen schien er zu jung
und zu wenig vertrauenswürdig.
Das ist schön.
Während Kevin und Lia
den Verstorbenen aufbahren,
treffe ich die Geschäftsführerin
des Krematoriums Bern:
Silvana Pletscher.
Auch sie musste
vor der Staatsanwaltschaft aussagen.
Wenn ich sehe,
wie viele Steuergelder,
die man anderweitig einsetzen
könnte, für etwas genutzt wurden,
das in irgendeiner Ecke
gestartet wurde ...
Und ...
Es kann sein,
dass etwas Wahres dran war.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Ich bin nicht draussen.
Ich schaue bei niemandem zu,
wie sie ihr Geschäft machen.
Aber er ist
sehr erfolgreich unterwegs.
War er.
Wir hatten viele gute Rückmeldungen.
Auch für uns.
Wenn wirklich etwas nicht
so gewesen ist, wie es sein sollte,
wäre das
nicht so lange gut gegangen.
Es ist einfach eine Verurteilung.
Eine Vorverurteilung.
Bevor man nur wusste, ob ...
... etwas an dem Ganzen dran ist.
Ich staunte auch darüber, dass er
an so vielen Verhören dabei war.
Dass er das aushielt.
Ich hätte ihn
sehr gerne an unserem Anlass ...
Wir machen ja einmal im Jahr
diesen Bestatteranlass.
Ich hätte ihn gerne dabeigehabt.
Aber er verzichtete darauf.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Es ist verständlich,
aber für mich gehörte er dorthin.
Er gehört klar hier dazu.
Bei diesem Bestatteranlass entstand
auch das Foto mit dem Handreichen.
Ich wusste nichts von diesem Foto.
Da machte ich mir
schon auch meine Gedanken.
Aber ja, das sind ja meine.
Haben Sie geschwiegen?
- Ich schweige, ja.
Kevin
hat viel Unterstützung erfahren -
von Freunden,
auch von einigen Bestattern,
von seiner Mutter
und von Lias Eltern.
Diese besuchen sie nun im Emmental.
Hoi. Bs, bs.
Hi.
Sali, tschau.
- Hallo.
Liana.
- Tschau, Kevin.
Fit und gesund?
- Hallo.- Ja.
Du auch?
- Viel Arbeit.- Es war streng.
(Mutter) Haben wir alles?
Äh ... Pfanne ... Die ist hier.
Wir sagten,
wir würden hinter ihnen stehen:
"Wir helfen, wenn es Probleme gibt."
"Ihr könnt jederzeit
auf uns zählen."
Es ist wichtig,
dass man ihn so etwas festigt.
Damit er nicht in ein Loch fällt.
Ja.
So ist er
wieder auf dem aufsteigenden Ast.
Aber nicht mehr so rasant,
wie in den jungen Jahren.
Du hast mit Kevin zusammengearbeitet.
- Genau.
Warum eckt er so an?
Was ist das Problem?
Ich glaube, er polarisiert einfach
mit seiner Jugendlichkeit
und Frische.
Und auch mit seinen Ideen.
Ich denke, es ist das. Ich kann
es mir nicht anders erklären.
Die Ideen
gehen Kevin nicht so schnell aus.
Er will mithilfe
seiner Schwiegereltern in spe
auch im Emmental
Bestattungen anbieten.
Falls gewünscht,
kann die Asche der Verstorbenen
bei ihnen
unter einem Baum bestattet werden.
Das ist der Platz im Emmental,
den wir geschaffen haben.
Ich kann hier mit den Schwieger-
eltern eine Gedenkstätte anbieten.
Das ist ein Traum, wenn man hier
die letzte Ruhe haben kann.
(Diana) Ja, ruhig ist es hier.
Also, cheers.
- Zum Wohl.
Gesundheit.
- Schatzi, Santé.
Diana Wälti hat bereits bei Kevin
im Unternehmen mitgearbeitet.
Sie weiss, wie er im Alltag tickt.
- Es könnte kühler sein.
Wo glaubst du,
hat er einen Fehler gemacht?
Ich denke, dass das
auch jugendlicher Leichtsinn war.
Dieses Vorpreschen
und halt eben die Hörner einstossen.
So nennt man das.
Ich war auch
jugendlich leichtsinnig
und machte viele Fehler,
aber ich kam nicht im "Blick".
Man überlegt sich
immer mal wieder ...
Man muss klar differenzieren,
was unternehmerische Fehler waren
oder - wie ich dargestellt wurde -
Straffälliges.
Wir wurden nie straffällig.
Ich wurde wegen der Mehrwertsteuer
angegriffen,
weil wir die Mehrwertsteuer
dazurechnen.
Aber im Dienstleistungsgewerbe
ist das gang und gäbe.
99 Bestatter - jetzt in
meiner Branche - rechnen das dazu.
Es ist immer das Material
plus die Mehrwertsteuer.
Aber da mussten wir dazulernen.
Vielleicht muss man
noch mehr auf die Leute zugehen.
Das war eine Handvoll Leute
von über 1'000 Bestattungen,
die wir hatten.
Aber wir gehen auf die fünf Leute
zu, die ein Problem damit hatten.
Kevin arbeitet unaufhörlich
in seiner Firma.
Er ist sieben Tage pro Woche
erreichbar, 24 Std. am Tag.
Es gibt keinen Auftrag,
den er ablehnt.
Dann kannst du
noch die Blumen nehmen.- Mhm.
Merci. Bis nachher.
- Bis nachher.
In den letzten acht Jahren
Selbstständigkeit
war ich gesamthaft fünf Tage weg.
Das ist halt "selbst" und "ständig".
Das ist dann das Motto.
Aber mir passt das.
Es stimmt im Moment so.
Der Fall heute: ein Polizeieinsatz.
Ein junger Mann wird tot aufgefunden.
Er hat keine Hinterbliebenen
und wird zum Bestatten freigegeben.
Kleider
hat der Herr auch nicht mehr.
Er ist wirklich verwahrlost.
Ganz allein.
Es gibt niemanden,
der etwas organisiert.
Wir ziehen ihm
eines unserer Sterbehemden an.
Damit er auf dem letzten Weg
etwas Würdiges trägt.
Wer für die Kosten der Bestattung
aufkommt, ist unklar.
Trotzdem
betreuen die beiden den Fall weiter.
Wir nehmen ...
Ja, das ist eigentlich das ...
... berufliche Risiko,
das man halt hat.
Aber ich spende sonst nirgends etwas
und finanziere hier jemandem ...
... eine Bestattung mit.
Ich kann so etwas anbieten.
Bei ihm muss man schauen,
ob die Gemeinde schlussendlich ...
Die Gemeinde müsste ja für eine
schickliche Bestattung aufkommen.
Aber das ist dann manchmal auch ein
behördlicher Spiessroutenlauf ...
... den man jeweils
fast juristisch angehen müsste,
um zum Geld zu kommen.
Das ist nicht immer einfach.
Es gibt auch viele Gemeinden,
die das sauber gelöst haben.
Du bist ja kein Wohltäter.
Du tust so,
als würde es nicht ums Geld gehen.
Nein, klar, schlussendlich verdienen
wir unser Leben mit dem Tod.
Wir können das
natürlich nicht gratis machen.
Das ist so.
- Bleiben wir bei Weiss?
Zwei ...
Oder die ganz links. Genau.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ich finde es so gut. Du?
Dann können wir
das Oberteil draufmachen.
Der war jetzt nicht so alt.
- Nein. Gar nicht.
Was macht das mit dir?
Ja, das ist speziell.
"Die Uhr ist gestellt",
sage ich jeweils.
Zum Glück wissen wir das nicht.
Für die Hinterbliebenen
ist es traurig.
Für sie selber auch.
Zack und weg ist man.
Das
kann man nicht rückgängig machen.
Das überlegt man schon.
Wir sprechen zu Hause auch darüber.
Gerade, wenn sie so jung sind.
Eigentlich
muss man jede Sekunde geniessen
und dankbar sein.
Wenn man einen Traum hat,
soll man sich den ermöglichen.
So schnell wie möglich. Jetzt.
Das macht Kevin.
Er lebt seinen Traum.
Dieser kollidiert aber ab und zu
mit den Träumen anderer Bestatter.
So auch mit Gyan Härri.
Der Streitpunkt:
Kevin betreute einen Sterbefall,
für den später
auch Gyan Härri aufgeboten wurde.
Als wir
den Auftrag der Familie erhielten,
um den Todesfall weiter zu betreuen,
riefen wir ihn
bzw. seinen Mitarbeiter an.
Er war aber auch involviert.
Da wurde immer rückgefragt.
Wir wollten die verstorbene Person
abholen
und da hiess es, die Familie
müsse zuerst die Rechnung bezahlen.
Das ist ja überhaupt nicht Usus
in dieser Branche.
Das macht man nicht so.
In meinen Augen ist das z.B.
bei einem Auslandtransport legitim.
Oder auch sonst,
dass man den Kunden sagt,
dass man die Rechnung vor der
Dienstleistung bezahlt haben will.
Ich finde das sehr unüblich.
Abgesehen
von einem Auslandtransport
würden wir das nicht so machen,
aber das ist wieder Marktfreiheit,
das darf jeder.
Was aber nicht geht:
Eine Dienstleistung zu erbringen
und danach die verstorbene Person
als Faustpfand zu nehmen.
Was müsste Kevin Huguenin ändern,
um aufgenommen zu werden?
Nur einen Schritt nach vorne machen.
Einen Schritt auf uns zu.
Wir haben die Tür geöffnet
und ihm die Hand entgegengestreckt.
Nicht viel.
Es braucht sicher etwas Zeit, damit
Gras über die Wunde wachsen kann.
Die Leute müssen merken,
dass er sich verändert hat.
Das ist alles.
Kevins Version dieser Geschichte
klingt anders.
Da geht es
nicht um eine unbezahlte Rechnung,
sondern um einen Auftrag,
der offenbar doppelt vergeben wurde.
Es ging so:
Jemand aus der Familie ...
... des Verstorbenen
hat aurora beauftragt.
Der Vater beauftragte aber uns.
Wir hatten den Auftrag ganz klar.
Dann meldete sich aurora und sagte,
wir müssten den rausgeben,
sie hätten ab jetzt den Auftrag.
Sie kämen jetzt.
Und ich sagte, ich würde den
Verstorbenen sicher nicht rausgeben.
Ich muss ja zuerst von meinem
Auftraggeber das Okay kriegen
und den Rückzug des Auftrags,
was ich bis dahin nicht glaubte.
Das war einfach jemand
aus der Familie, der aurora wollte.
Das ist ja alles okay.
Wir sagten ganz klar,
wenn er schon käme ...
... müsse man auch klären,
wer die Kosten übernimmt.
Man ruft sicher nicht einfach an
und holt so jemanden ab.
Man klärt das zuerst.
Das geht nicht Tage,
sondern ein paar Stunden.
Was kannst du dazu beitragen,
dass diese Situation ...
... wieder besser wird?
Das ist ja kein Zustand auf Dauer.
In Zukunft sollte man
halt auf die Leute zugehen,
anstatt sie medial blosszustellen.
Ich hatte
immer wieder gute Gespräche,
in Krematorien oder Friedhöfen,
wenn ich Bestatter getroffen habe.
Da kam es
immer wieder zu Gesprächen.
Es muss ja nicht viel sein.
Einfach, dass ich
vielleicht aktiv auf sie zugehe.
Das könntest du ja machen.
- Das müsste ich wahrscheinlich.
Kevin versucht,
sich der Branche anzunähern.
Sein oberstes Credo aber
bleibt die Individualität.
So auch hier in Aarberg.
Die Abdankung einer Frau
findet nicht in einer Kirche,
sondern in einem Restaurant statt.
Wir arbeiten nachher
noch mit den Tüchern.
Wie viel Erfindergeist ist in diesem
Traditionsmetier überhaupt erlaubt?
Es muss sich
im legalen Bereich abspielen.
Wir können niemanden
auf den Mond schiessen.
Dazu würde mir die Rakete fehlen.
Aber man versucht vieles.
Wir versuchen,
möglichst alles zu erfüllen,
anstatt es einfach nur wie früher
zu machen und fertig.
Wir wollen etwas offen denken.
Guten Tag, Nadia. Hallo.
Meine Güte, ist das schön.
- (Mann) Wunderbar.
Wunderschön.
- (Kevin) Passt das so?
Vielen herzlichen Dank.
- Sehr gerne. Von Herzen.
Schöner könnte man es nicht machen.
Ist es so,
wie Sie es sich vorgestellt haben?
Das ist schöner
als an meiner Hochzeit.
(Mann) Nicht ganz.
- Fantastisch.
Nicht ganz so schön
wie an unserer Hochzeit.
Die Familie hat Kevin
schon zum zweiten Mal engagiert.
Wunderschön,
mit diesen Kerzen im Blumenmeer.
Bei Kevin
spürte ich von Anfang an stark ...
... dass er für diesen Beruf,
für diese Berufung, geboren ist.
Das sind ...
... die Redensart, die Tonalität,
die Poesie während des Gesprächs -
das kann man nicht lernen.
Das kriegt man mit.
Das ist tief im Herzen.
* Romantische Musik *
Um das Geschäft weiter anzukurbeln,
eröffnet Kevin
auch in Thun eine Filiale.
Die Strategie:
mehr Sichtbarkeit, mehr Aufträge.
Die Auftragslage
ist allerdings immer noch ernst:
Bei rund einem Drittel
im Vergleich zu früher.
Es sieht schon ... Vielleicht
müssen wir das austauschen.
Quasi ...
Ich sage immer:
"Es kommt, wie es muss."
Ja, man kann immer etwas machen.
Wir sind noch jung.
Ich hatte eigentlich nie Angst.
* Emotionale Musik *
Diese neue Filiale erinnert mich
eher an eine Wellnessoase
als an einen Ort,
wo der Tod im Zentrum steht.
Anstelle eines Kreuzes setzt Kevin
Huguenin auf einen Schmetterling.
Diese Idee bietet er überall an.
Wir arbeiten im ganzen Kanton.
Wir gehen dorthin,
wo wir gerufen werden.
Mit unseren Bürostandorten
können wir überall
jemanden bei uns empfangen.
Aber gerade das
macht die Konkurrenz ja so wütend.
Klar. Man ist überall
ein bisschen vertreten
und halt bei allen
ein bisschen in ihrem Rayon drin.
Das kommt ja schon immer mehr.
Nur schon die Unternehmen
hier rundherum -
wenn ich denke, wie viele Standorte
die überall haben ...
Oder der Grosse,
der im Inselspital in Bern ist:
Er hat überall Filialen und Büros.
Auch hier unten.
Das kommt immer mehr.
Da bist du nicht mehr der Einzige,
der das so macht.
Du warst vielleicht
einer der Ersten, aber ...
Das ist jetzt normal.
- Da fuhr gerade einer durch.
Kevin hat in der Bestatterszene
offenbar etwas bewegt.
Auch zwischen ihm und Gyan Härri,
mit dem er sich um die Herausgabe
eines Verstorbenen stritt,
hat sich etwas getan.
Hast du eigentlich mal Kontakt
mit der Konkurrenz aufgenommen?
Ja. Gerade vor rund einer Woche
traf ich mich mit Gyan.
Wir lernten uns so
eigentlich zum ersten Mal kennen.
Wir hatten uns ja noch nie richtig
gesehen oder miteinander gesprochen.
Mir war es wichtig,
das ohne Medien zu tun.
Also 1:1, mit Menschlichkeit.
Das war ...
Das war eigentlich
ein gutes Gespräch, oder?
Definitiv.
Mir war es wichtig, ihm aufzuzeigen,
warum wir ihm den Verstorbenen
nicht rausgegeben haben.
Er wusste auch nicht, dass der Vater
uns den Auftrag gegeben hatte,
weil wir
nicht miteinander gesprochen haben.
Ich habe auch daraus gelernt.
Ich habe ihn dort wie abgelehnt
und gesagt,
wir würden
zuerst mit unserem Kunden sprechen,
bevor wir mit ihm weiterschauen.
Da würden wir heute
auch anders vorgehen.
Man lernt immer dazu.
Das klingt nach einem Happy End.
- Ja, Happy End ...
Das war spannend: Er erzählte dann
eine ähnliche Geschichte davon,
wie er anfing.
Er erzählte uns,
dass er auch keine Lehre habe -
wie ich auch nicht.
Letztlich sind wir ziemlich ähnlich.
Ein Jahr
nach der Einstellung des Verfahrens
haben sie
rund die Hälfte der Aufträge
eines durchschnittlichen Monats
vor der Krise.
Sie sind heil angekommen. Gut.
- Mhm. Die sehen noch gut aus.
Das wäre das Schlimmste gewesen,
wenn das nie mehr angelaufen wäre.
Dann hätte es immer geheissen:
"Das war dieser Betrugsbestatter,
dieser Wucherbestatter."
Und das waren wir nicht.
Damit hätte ich ein Problem gehabt.
Ich habe auch dafür gekämpft.
Zusammen mit dem Team.
Das war nicht nur ich allein.
Da ist viel gegangen.
Schlussendlich
können wir stolz sein.
Hier geben sie
einer Frau die letzte Ruhe.
Nach der Kremation vor sieben Jahren
wurde sie nie abgeholt.
Die Urne
stand seitdem bei ihm im Regal.
Leider keine Seltenheit heutzutage,
sagen sie mir.
Kevin und Lia
sind mit Leib und Seele Bestatter.
Nach dieser turbulenten Zeit
rund um das Verfahren umso mehr.
Die Beziehung ist stärker geworden.
Man lernte sich besser kennen.
Man sah Emotionen, die man vorher
vielleicht nicht kannte.
Dieses Verlorensein
in der Situation.
Und sich dann wieder zu stärken ...
... nach vorne zu schauen
und wieder Ehrgeiz ...
Wir haben viele
wechselhafte Emotionen durchgemacht.
Vom letzten Jahr nehme ich mit,
vielleicht
einen Gang runterzuschalten ...
... und alles etwas genauer
zu überlegen,
anstatt Schnellschüsse zu machen.
Aber letztlich werden wir
an der Arbeit mit den Familien und
mit den Verstorbenen nichts ändern.
Das werden wir
genau gleich weitermachen.
Kevin hat es geschafft,
sich aus einer fast
ausweglosen Situation zu befreien.
Um in einer Branche,
die so stark auf Vertrauen basiert,
seinen Ruf wiederherzustellen,
dauert aber wohl noch länger.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023